last time you were here you had just
gotten married you had just gotten
married and i'm wondering
you know yeah very nice it's good thank
you this is a good thing
how's your wife meredith doing how is
the marriage going meredith is
amazing uh she has been
i mean she's basically turned every she
she took me from the depths of despair
and not only got me back to normal but
then
took me to some heights i didn't kind of
know existed
in terms of happiness um that not to say
that everything is
perfect um a couple months ago
um before i tell the story everything
that she did in the story she did with
utmost love and and good intentions okay
but we got into a huge blowout fight
and it was one of those fights where i'm
like i'm i'm gonna go i'm gonna go on a
hike i left the house to go on a hike
right and blow off steam and she went
fine go on your stupid hike so
halfway through my hike i it hit me
i'm being ridiculous this is i'm being
so stupid
what what is this about we're fighting
over nothing and unbeknownst to me she
was home
also going what do we do this is so dumb
we're acting like
eight-year-olds so she knows where i go
in my head because she goes with me
sometimes
and so she knows where i come out when
that when the hike is over where i park
my car
so she went to the parking lot
and put and i brought it i want you to
look at this she left she put this note
under my windshield from when i came
when i finished the hike okay
i'm going to read you the note this is
the note all right and you can maybe do
a close-up later
so i'm done with the hike i get to my
card this note is on my windshield
i take it off i open it up first word
stop period
you can actually see stop all right then
get out of your car period
walk to the park bench in front of you
period
and then finally i love you period
now yeah i love you that's beautiful
that is a long
terrifying walk to i love you
well you're sitting there at a car
you're like stop get out of your car
i'm uh immediately i like look for a
laser dot like on my
like this is what a psychotic man would
leave
on a windshield and then i also realized
like and then when 11 oh and then she
was over
there but this cheat the pacing of this
is the same pacing that you would be
like when you get that call like
if your child or loved one is kidnapped
yeah and they use the weird voice
changer
yeah you know what by the way if if that
was happening then the i love
you becomes the most terrifying part
where you're like stop get out of your
car
walk to the park bench in front of you i
love you
uh that's fantastic thank you but yeah
yeah it wasn't so much fun to live
but it was yeah it's a good fight sir
it's all part of it you're fighting and
arguing it's all part of it